Let's begin and start talking about the stage setup
and the various pieces of hardware
that you'll be utilizing in a common LED volume.
First off, there's some certain configurations
and considerations that you should take into account.
When LED volumes were first thought of and considered,
they kind of went through a bit of an evolution.
We started off with some various flat configurations,
kind of like what we have here at the LED,
at the latte stage here in Culver City.
These flat configurations were basically flat walls
with right angles,
and they were really kind of difficult to light.
Obviously, when you're dealing with a flat wall
and you're standing here,
you're getting a lot of this backlight
on the actor itself.
So this became a bit of an issue and problematic.
So this heavy backlight required a lot of
bright practical lights,
which caused issues with spill on the stage themselves.
And it also introduced potential problems
for various issues with dealing
with environmental reflections on the stage.
So the stage evolved basically
into a more curved configuration.
And this first started out by having purely cylindrical,
like 100% nearly round stage configurations,
which worked, but they had specific acoustical problems.
Completely round stages,
the sound within the stage was very pronounced
and it echoed everywhere.
So the stage kind of evolved
into a more of a horseshoe shape or U shape.
And this is where we see the majority of most stages
today in their stage of evolution.
The horseshoe shape allowed for the reduction
of echo and acoustical problems.
They were reduced with the horseshoe design
and they introduced the concept of including a plug wall,
which is basically a wall that could either come down
like a garage door or rotated in from the sides
to seal the entire environment
to allow for full 360 degree shooting.
When we're considering a location for an actual stage,
here are some things
that you should really pay attention to.
Number one, the stage should have,
and the building that you're planning
on building this stage in,
there should be a very clear span up in the ceiling.
The ceiling height is critical and important
for being able to have something able or multi-story
that you might want to shoot.
But in addition to the height of the ceiling
and not having anything that's obstructing the ceiling
in the various spans,
you need to make sure that the ceiling is capable
of supporting a great amount of weight.
Because depending upon how you configure your stage,
whether you're setting it up a hanging truss
or if you're having it actually configured
to sit on the ground,
the ceiling weight capacity is going to be a big deal.
And the fact that you're gonna need
to have really high impact and dense concrete
for the flooring is going to be necessary.
Any kind of vibration that might be introduced
from the flooring of moving objects around
can potentially destabilize and or require you
to calibrate your motion capture cameras multiple times,
especially if you're moving the large plug wall,
it can really cause a lot of various vibrations.
So the floors have to be made
of a very strong high impact concrete to absorb vibration.
You need to make sure
that your facility has adequate power.
Obviously when you're dealing with so many LED panels
and you've got lighting and you've got HVAC
and you've got computers,
your building has to have sufficient power
to be able to drive all of this.
Soundproofing of course is important.
The issue of course with the wall acoustically
is difficult enough as it is.
If you're in some sort of facility that isn't soundproof,
you're going to have problems
and your audio technicians will not be happy about it.
Air conditioning, big issue.
The panels give off heat.
Certainly they give off less heat than practical lights,
but they still generate heat
and all the various computer systems associated do as well.
So if you don't have good HVAC systems
to keep your environment cool,
you could potentially run into problems or issues there.
You should also have obviously a series of offices
for your production staff.
You need an area to be a mill space
to help construct practical set pieces
outside of the actual volume itself
that you can eventually move on to the volume.
And of course, you're going to need some parking
for your facility because running these types of stages
do require a number of personnel.
So make sure that you have good parking for them.
The stages can be configured
in a number of different ways.
We've just simplified it here
and we're showing a large stage configuration,
a medium stage configuration
and a small stage configuration.
The NAND stage, one of our partners
has a facility in El Segundo, California.
This is a fairly large stage.
It's 50 foot wide by 30, or excuse me,
53 feet in length and 20 feet high.
It does have a ceiling element
and it has two plug walls that basically rotate
in front of the stage itself
for full 360 degree shooting.
Now the Epic R&D stage,
we consider this more of a medium stage,
31 feet in width, 23 feet in length
and 13 feet in height.
It does have a ceiling
and it does have separate wild walls
that can be moved into place for reflective elements
and or providing additional lighting.
It's 174 degrees,
but it also includes five flat columns of panels.
And this as a stage can certainly do a great job
for shooting a number of different elements.
It's not quite as encompassing as the large stage
and it doesn't have an actual raised floor.
So you do have to be a little bit more careful
as to how you manage that seam transition
from the stage itself to the floor.
But this would be a medium sized stage.
And then finally, the small stage here
in Culver City, we have our latte stage.
This is more of like a technical
or a tactical training stage.
It's 16 feet wide by eight feet in height.
And we also have a right angled wall to us as well here.
And we have a large television screen as a wild wall.
This is just a 4K high resolution TV screen
that can provide you with some extra reflections
and some potential additional lighting if necessary.
Now for a part of equipment,
there's a whole series of equipment
that we need to talk about.
We're gonna go through it first in the slides
and then we'll actually show you the latte stage
here in Culver City.
Okay, so first is the control cards.
These control cards are basically fundamental
in the actual volume itself.
It's kind of where the traditional brain bar
would be located, even though that term
isn't really quite utilized anymore.
It's kind of going out of fashion.
The control cards basically house your various stations
that are controlling Unreal Engine.
And you'll have one for the actual control of the engine.
You'll have one probably for secondary purposes
like a multi-purpose cart for helping prep
and set up various shots in preparation.
They're not cheap.
They can range anywhere from 5,000 to $7,500 per cart,
but they're really great in the sense
that they can be moved around on stage,
relocated and repositioned
depending upon your configuration and needs.
Next, we have our Q-Take system
and our Mac Pro.
I just want to also point out,
these are the carts and devices
that we're using at the LA R&D stage in El Segundo.
So we have a Q-Take system.
This is basically a video assist machine
that records everything that's being captured on the camera.
It is a Mac-based system,
and it's a pretty expensive device.
It's around $100,000 for this entire system,
but it does handle all of the recording and playback
and video assist for productions
that are being conducted on stage.
Next, we have the ThinkLogical 10 gigabit
KVM switching matrix.
This is basically,
this allows us to basically relocate our CPUs
into a cooled machine room.
And then this device connects up to those machines
so that you can have your keyboard,
video and mouse controls
routed to a different portion of your stage.
And we basically have this set up
for all the individual carts.
All the carts within the stage
have the ability to switch between different machines
that they're controlling
and the video that's coming into the monitors.
So you're going to need something that'll help
to route your keyboard and video and mouse functions.
There's the switch price
and then all the individual extensions.
It can add up,
but it's really an important piece to have
so you can keep a lot of the machines off stage
and in a more cooled machine room.
Now, speaking of computer systems,
we have a number of them.
I talked about the control cart and the control machines.
Well, these are a series of AMD workstations
that are prepped and loaded
to basically ingest and bring in Unreal Engine content
and prepare it for the stage
in order to get it ready for use.
So these machines,
just their base price is probably about $5,000,
but it goes way up past that.
You've got to add in additional memory,
various hard drives
and a really decent graphics card is necessary
for these control machines.
Now, these control machines do not actually send
and transact data up onto the wall,
but you still need to have a powerful graphics card
inside of these machines
in order to basically prep and set up
what will be transacted to the wall.
So probably would recommend the higher RTX Titan machines
or 30, it could be 30 90s or 40 90s
or any of the Quadro based graphics cards are great too.
Anything with a lot of video card memory
is probably the best choice.
Next, there's a whole series of render computers.
These are also AMD workstations.
Again, base price $5,000,
but probably even more,
more in the neighborhood of 15 to $20,000
once they're fully decked out
with all the necessary RAM and hard drives and so forth.
But they are also equipped with two highly specific GPUs.
The A6000 typically is what we prefer.
This is a Quadro based card
that's capable of handling synchronization,
which is important, mandatory even
for the whole LED process.
You're gonna have two of these GPUs
in each individual machine
and they are basically linked together via SLI
so that the two graphics cards
are talking with one another
and that factors in to how Unreal Engine draws
the content on the screen,
what's inside of the frustum and what's outside.
I mentioned the GPU, there's the Nvidia A6000 card.
This is basically about $5,500 per graphics card.
It needs to be combined with the Quadro Sync 2 card,
which is the card it utilizes for gen locking purposes.
So gen locking is a big part of this equation,
something that we'll talk about in just a moment,
but you need to have not only those two graphics cards
in these machines, but also the Quadro Sync card,
which will then link to every other rendering machine
in your machine room.
All right, other potential hardware and video gear
that you're going to need,
timecode, timecode sync, gen lock.
These are, again, critical components.
In the R&D stage, we have the Everett's
and Brainstorm solutions.
These basically, again, provide house timecode
and house gen lock to all the devices
that are either in the machine room,
like your render machines, your control machines
and so forth, but then they also supply gen lock
to your motion capture cameras
and also to your video assist in recording
and the actual camera that you're using itself
to film all of this.
So critical component, you have to have
some kind of timecode and gen lock generation.
We also have an HDMI matrix router.
Now this is the Lightware MX2.
This is a zero latency HDMI video router.
Now, all of the A6000 cards in your render machines,
they all have display ports out of them.
So this will take the display port
and convert it into an HDMI signal
and allow you to route the video output
from any of your render machines
wherever you need it to go.
So this basically combines and sends all this information
to your megapixel or any other brand
that you might be using of your LED processor.
So it converts display port into HDMI
and that signal is then sent to your LED processors.
This is a fairly expensive piece of equipment.
It's about $50,000, but it's pretty critical to have.
If you don't have it,
you're gonna have to be sending individual signals
from each individual machine
and that's a lot of extra cabling.
This simplifies a lot.
Now, the next item that we have on this slide
is the HDMI distribution and monitoring system.
This is a bit of a luxury item, quite frankly.
This is the Barco E2.
This basically combines a number of multiple video signals
into a single signal, and that's hard to say,
that is then projected for your stage operators to see.
So these are $85,000 a piece,
but basically at a glance, your cinematographer,
your director, your virtual production supervisor
can look at these monitors on stage
and know exactly which machine is rendering what.
And you can see an entire amalgamation
of all of these video signals on one monitor.
Really helpful and handy.
This is an example of what the Barco will do for you.
Just to kind of give you an example
of what's being seen, the image on the left
is basically, like I said,
a composite of all the incoming video signals
from all the render boxes that are being driven
by NDisplay and Unreal Engine.
Very helpful, very informative,
and really gives your directors
and virtual production supervisors some extra help.
All right, now we also have LED wall technology
and processors that we need to discuss.
We have the Brompton processors and megapixel processors
that are commonly used at the stages that we have.
In this example, I'm showing you the Brompton Tessera SX40.
That's what's driving the particular wall
here at the latte stage.
This basically converts 4K video into 10 gig IP video.
Now, this IP video then travels over fiber optic wire
to your distribution nodes,
which typically are located behind the wall.
And we're gonna look at all that here on the stage
in just a moment.
So the distribution nodes take the 10 gigabit signal
from the processors and break that video up
into one gigabit signals,
which are daisy chained to all of your different LED
panels.
And the LED panels that we use at the R&D stage at Nant
and here at the latte stage
are the Rode Black Pearl II panels.
These are 2.8 millimeter pixel pitch panels, 1,500 nits.
They consume about 160 Watts.
And they're gonna be priced somewhere in the neighborhood
of about 2,500, maybe $3,000 per panel.
Now, we're gonna talk a little bit more
about the LED volume.
First, I'll show you this particular slide.
Here at the latte stage, we have, as mentioned,
the Rode Black Pearl II panels.
This is our hardware panel configuration.
These panels contain 176 by 176 LED picture elements
on each panel.
Again, the pixel pitch is 2.8 millimeters
and our wall is configured basically
to have 10 of these panels across
by five panels high for the main wall.
And then the side wall at 90 degrees
is a five by five panel.
You can see by the pixel resolution,
it's not exceptionally high resolution.
It's 1,076 pixels by 880 pixels for the main wall
and 880 by 880 pixels on the side wall.
The wild wall that we have, the 4K TV,
which is the Sony 85 inch 4K LED screen.
This is also, like I said, it's used for multipurposes.
It can be added for additional light.
It can be added for additional reflection.
It has a total resolution of 4K, 3840 by 2160.
And we use that for a number of different purposes.
So with this, we're going to go ahead
and switch over to seeing the entire facility
via a roving camera.